43 million dollars is this a lot of
money for HSBC no not much oh really
it's really just pennies from a bank as
big as HSBC but it is a big deal for
Geneva the man of the hour is the chief
prosecutor Olivier Giorno he says we're
not trying to break any Guinness World
Records here but this is the largest sum
any institution has ever had to pay to
Geneva so seems like Switzerland inching
towards some type of reform at least
from the prosecutor he says he's hoping
for that but this 43 million dollars
does include an estimate of the profits
the bank made from the accounts under
scrutiny also the cost from damages as
well but the prosecutors saying the bank
will face no criminal charges and no
current HSV staff HSBC staff will be
charged so in the email statement this
is what HSBC said they said that they
will be paying these quote past paying
for these paths organizational
deficiencies and so the HSBC private
bank has acknowledged at the compliance
culture and standards and due diligence
in place in the past was not as robust
as today they keep saying that they've
done this radical transformation they've
changed their compliance codes they've
cut seventy percent of his client base
to about 10,000 now this matter though
the prosecutor is saying shows them how
weak the Swiss law is when it comes to
these criminal funds and how they enter
into these financial market you know 43
million dollars really another hit in
this series of hits at HSBC is has had
to feel yes as it prepares to cut more
costs yes according to sources are
they're telling us that deeper cuts may
be coming to the investment bank
particularly the equities trading
division lowest return on equity should
be the first in line for cuts of course
the CEO Stuart Gulliver is going to be
speaking to shareholders next week
updating some of those plans they said
that thousands according to sources job
cuts could be in the line here